hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video und
können mit sicherheit schon am titel des
videos erkennen es geht um youtube und
ist die in letzter zeit ein bisschen
blödsinn übrigens wäre ich am ende des
videos auch diese kennen der in excel
kamera verlosen unter euch allen also
bleibt auf jeden fall bis zum ende dran
ich finde genug youtuber haben zu diesem
ganzen thema schon videos gemacht hast
recht machen ich wollte mich dazu
eigentlich gar nicht äußern weil ich
habe sich ja gerade eingeblendet das
haben schon enorm viel getan aber hey
luca warum worum geht's es geht darum
dass youtube etwas an der seite
verändert hat beziehungsweise an dem
algorithmus der seite so dass wenn ihr
zum beispiel einen youtube abonniert
habt ihr die videos nicht mehr deshalb
box angezeigt bekommt oder allgemein den
kanal noch einmal de abonniert haben
obwohl er das gar nicht wollte oder gar
nicht getan habt jetzt geht darum dass
youtube immer wieder neue änderungen
einführen wie beispielsweise bei der
kommentar sektion dazu habe ich auch
schon mal ein video hochgeladen und zwar
die aktiviere ich die bewertungen hat
heute für eine woche
es sind einfach ganz ganz viele
kleinigkeiten die die leute an youtube
stört aber jetzt in letzter zeit war es
wirklich enorm viel was youtube einfach
falsch gemacht hat allein diese tatsache
dass die erste seite wenn man auf
youtube geht der erste teil ist nicht
mehr der die seite von den leuten die
man abonniert hat sondern irgendwas
empfohlen ist das ist noch schlimmer als
facebook mit der entwicklung bei
facebook finde ich ja schon schlimm dass
man beispielsweise auch die seite geht
und man sieht nicht mehr die beiträge
von seinen freunden oder so sondern nur
noch irgendwelche seiten die videos
posten uns wie man gar keinen
persönlichen kontakte was verein
überhaupt persönlich gar keine relevanz
hat aber youtube viel krasser sie zeigen
nicht mehr nur die sachen an die
irgendwie gepostet werden oder keine
ahnung was machen sie ja nicht mehr sie
zeigen einfach eben etwas an was einem
einfach wir wollen wir das ist wenn ich
das nicht sehen will ich will ich will
eigentlich auf youtube nur dass zehn von
den leuten sich abonniert haben
natürlich gibt es auch noch die
abonnement spalte und so aber die ist
einfach links am rande da muss man erst
mal sein video aufklappen keine ahnung
was sie bereits jetzt schon mehrmals in
dem video gesagt wollte ich mich dazu
gar nicht so riesig zu äußern allerdings
habe ich jetzt vor ein paar tagen e mail
bekommen von dinosaurier hd hallo seit
tagen bekomme ich keine videos mehr von
ihnen die abo box sollte das nun mal
gesagt haben um bei twitter wurde mir
auch einiges wie zugesandten vom gegen
läuse letzte woche wurde einfach mein
abo bei de gelöscht obwohl ich dich
aktiver schauer als alle anderen und
deswegen leute ich weiß nicht warum
youtube das gemacht hat aber sie zu
erstellen damit eigentlich ihre eigene
plattform und verärgern die traders und
verärgern euch also denken
mir wurde allerdings auch mehrfach
gesagt von sehr vielen leuten von euch
wie man das ganze fixen kann also unter
meinem video steht ja mein name kong
crafter schrägstrich luca und da müsst
ihr einfach mal auf die glocke
draufklicken neben dem abonnieren
zeichen und wenn ihr da drauf gelegt
habt bekommen wir dieses fenster hier
von wegen benachrichtigungen von con
crafter schrecklich luca dort müsste
jetzt ankreuzen ich möchte alle
mitteilungen zu diesem kanal erhalten
was ihr damit jetzt quasi gemacht habe
ist dass ihr einfach mitteilungen der e
mail erhalte ich weiß nicht wie oft ihr
euren e mail posteingang checks
allerdings immer wenn ich dann was
hochladen und das ist eigentlich
höchstens einmal täglich bekommen wir
dann einfach eine kleine mail von wegen
kräfte an ein neues video hochgeladen
und da erfahren wir dann dass ich an
euch hochgeladen habe weil bei
youtube.de ganzen kommentaren und
antworten zu mir sehen die hälfte meiner
zuschauer gar nicht dass ich irgendwas
hochladen das erstmal zu dieser youtube
sache ich will da gar nichts die
plattform youtube sind rasseln ich will
nicht sagen dass ich meinen kanal lösche
bei ihnen näher bestimmten zahl von
abonnenten ich denke dass youtube weiß
was da abgeht und weiß auch wie man das
fixen kann und ich bin mir sicher dass
die leute bei youtube da schon dahinter
sind das irgendwie zu machen allerdings
bitte ich euch dass ihr einfach auf
diese glocke klickt und die
benachrichtigungen an macht das haben
wir auch schon sehr sehr viele große
deutsche youtuber gesagt und dadurch
kriegt ihr auf jeden fall mit wenig
neues video hochgeladen habe und jetzt
zum gewinnspiel ich habe ja vor zwei
wochen in einem video bereits gesagt das
heißt heute könnt ihr was gewinnen
den zehnten dezember danach die woche
samstag den 17 dezember unter nach
heiligabend also dem 24
ich halt an dem ersten samstag mit
playstation 4 verlost an dem zweiten
samstag habe ich eine nintendo 3ds xl
verlost und dem heutigen video verlose
ich eine kenneth archer
das ist die kamera mit der ich unter
anderem blogs mache und eigentlich alle
youtuber wenn ihr also diese kamera hier
gewinnen wollte und ich die euch zu
schicken soll dann gibt es eigentlich
nur zwei sachen die ihr machen müsst die
erste sagt dann ist ihr müsst meinen
kanal abonnieren das heißt einfach unter
dem video abonnieren klicken und dann
halt auf diese glocke damit ihr halt die
uploads nicht mehr verpassen die zweite
sache die beachten müsste ist einfach
dass sie einen kommentar schreibt wie
ich erreichen kann also sowas wie
beispielsweise bei instagram oder bei
twitter heißt der sind auch schon alle
regeln beachten müsst und wenn ihr das
getan haben einen kanal abonniert hatten
kommentar geschrieben habt gebt ihr
automatisch am gewinnspiel teil und
könnten vielleicht diese kamera gewinnen
die ich am liebsten selber haben würde
aber hey es ist weihnachten und ich mag
euch in die märkte verschenken die packe
ich jetzt vielleicht auch hey wer hat
denn den nintendo 3ds xl von letzter
woche bekommen ich wollte das eigentlich
gestern schon auflösen und ich weiß es
nicht gesagt hat dass jeden samstag
neues video kommt allerdings hatte ich
gestern keine zeit mehr
und habe noch meine oma besucht und so
weiter und so fort das waren dann
einfach wichtiger als dieses gewinnspiel
aufzulösen aber mein laptop durchstöbert
gerade die über 90.000 kommentare unter
dem gewinnspiel und ist gerade bei
kommentar 64.000 das heißt sie warten
einfach noch kurz und dann teile ich
euch den gewinner mit ri die seite ist
jetzt gerade alle 92.000 kommentare
unter dem video durchgegangen oder steht
jetzt krieg' button bjp corinna das
heißt wir klicken einfach mal auf
randomly pick winner und wir haben den
kommentar gamespot hd instagram gamer
unterstrich
herzlichen glückwunsch an dich ich hoffe
du hast viel spaß in den sn 3ds xl
ich werde dich jetzt die nächsten tage
einfach mal anschreiben und dann werden
wir alles wird bezüglich des
gewinnspiels so abklären und an dieser
stelle würde ich das video für heute
auch beenden
also ich wollte einfach mal meine
meinung kundtun zu der aktuellen youtube
situation und hab jetzt selber ein paar
tweets und emails zu der ganzen sache
bekommen das auch mich natürlich
betrifft wenn ihr diese kamera in ihr
gewinnen wollt und irgendwie anfangen
wollte mit youtube-videos oder zu
blocken ist auf jeden fall perfekt
geeignet oder einfach nur fotos zu
machen keine ahnung player auch keine
werbung für mara das ding ist einfach
cool wie gesagt abonniert einfach meinen
kanal und schreibt ein kommentar wie ich
euch erreichen kann und macht alle bitte
die glocke an damit ihr nichts mehr
verpasst wenn ich im gastro planer und
bomben das war jetzt ein intro video
news update gewinnspiel video
ich hoffe da stellt euch nicht ich
versuche es mal meine familie gerade
weil ich ja dann auch wieder weg bin für
mehrere wochen arbeitet komplett egal da
natürlich sollte hier